foreign
Mr Speaker I beg to move that the draft
Windsor framework Democratic scrutiny
regulations 2023 uh which they were they
called the house uh on 20th of March be
approved before I start Mr Speaker can I
mention that it is my normal practice to
take as many interventions as I possibly
can during a debate however this debate
is on a statutory instrument and
therefore Limited in time so I will take
interventions but I won't take the
normal number that I would and I will
try and mop up all the questions raised
in the debate at the end with the leave
of the house
the stoma break is at the heart of the
Westminster framework IT addresses the
Democratic deficit restores the balance
of the Belfast Good Friday agreement and
ends the prospect of dynamic alignment
it restores practical sovereignty to the
United Kingdom as a whole and to the
people of Northern Ireland in particular
I will give away to my
I thank my right number of friend for
giving way as someone who served in the
province during the troubles and saw
firsthand the pain and anger endured by
all communities does he agree with me
that the Windsor framework not only
restores the balance of the Belfast
agreement but also offers the province
much greater Prosperity by way of inward
investment
and greater prosperity
helps most situations
I thank my uncle friend for his inter
his uh his words and yes I do agree with
him entirely we are just coming up to
the celebration of the 25th anniversary
of the Belfast Good Friday agreement
which has built peace and stability
across Northern Ireland and I very much
hope as I do believe every single
politician from Northern Ireland does
that the next 25 years of the Belfast
Good Friday agreement augmented helped
Along by this Windsor framework will
bring an age of prosperity to Northern
Ireland like we've never seen before
um I'll take uh can I say I'll take
three members I'll go uh Mr Shannon
first sorry Mr Speaker can I thank the
the uh and the head of the head of the
other ones but it's always a pleasure
on the winter framework or as we in
unionism called The Windsor knot uh it's
not that they don't enjoys or receives
Union of support indeed the United
Kingdom gives the EU sovereignty over
the courts and Par over Northern Ireland
it has Isis respectfully to say because
I'm a spiteful person has been shoved
through the house by the government the
conservative and unionist party with
some dismay I actually questioned now
conservative and where is the unionist
in a form and a format that doesn't
allow for scrutiny or due processes and
on that point it's like this did
honorable members and others across this
house should take note and they should
vote against us outside today because it
is like Gravely important constitutional
issue and we're very concerned
I Thank The Honorable gentleman for his
words um which I fundamentally disagree
with I am a unionist I'm very proud to
be a unionist
um and I believe that the foundations of
this of of our wonderful country make it
all each of them make it stronger and I
do believe that this is a massive step
forward in both progress for Northern
Ireland but the the Union as well
um I I actually disagree with him
entirely on his point um this actually
adds to the Democratic scrutiny that is
available and as one of Michelle
barnier's former advisors put it it does
amount to a clear veto possibility for
the UK government directive by directive
at the behest of minority in the
Northern Ireland assembly I think people
who know what they're talking about
understand that this is a very very good
deal I'm happy to wait to The Honorable
gentlemen
you said it takes three three I think
about Donald Trump
who does the Secretary of State will
help me remember the cake Masters
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker
um
I want to say one thing to write a
gentleman which is he talks about
Prosperity but I have seed potato
Growers and my consistency telling me
that this framework is very welcome
indeed it means that they can access the
normal large market and in turn via that
via mechanism access to the Republic of
Ireland Market that is most welcome
that's about the prosperity of my
constituency and perhaps this may lead
to access to the Spanish and French
Market which could be useful in the
future so that's why I believe we should
support the framework
I thank the first gentleman for his very
very pro-unionist uh commentary he's
absolutely right this for sea potatoes
and for a whole host of other products
that were no longer being through the
protocol not available in Northern
Ireland The Windsor framework solves
those issues and opens that market up I
have to give away to the honor very
grateful prosecutors did to give me
wherefore I was gonna have to do a whole
lot of squats there just to get in
um one of the one of the criteria for
using the storm and breaker for signing
uh the petition says that MLA is it must
be individually and collectively seeking
in good faith to fully operate the
institutions including through the
nominees the ministers and support for
the normal operation of the assembly
does this mean that gem Alistair will be
excluded from using from signing that
petition
if if the assembly's sitting and he's
sitting in it which he would be as a
fully elected member
um uh from his political uh party
um then I'm absolutely sure he could
sign said uh said uh uh for the for the
Break
um I believe there was one more person
behind me
very grateful uh Mr Speaker could I
commend the Prime Minister and my right
on my friend for the work that he's done
does it not show that when you build
Bridges when you show pragmatism when
you work with our Continental colleagues
we can actually provide results does he
also agree that along with orcas along
with the parrot Summit and he did the
budget this is now a return to
statecraft that we want to see in number
10.
it is without doubt statecraft emanating
from number 10 and I pay tribute to the
Prime Minister for everything that he
does in that in that way I'm going to
continue just for a bit if I may I will
come back in in a moment but in a
democracy we all believe as Democrats
here people should have a say over any
change to the laws under which they live
but under the old protocol that was not
the case changes to laws were
automatically imposed on Northern
Ireland whether it wanted them or not
and a secretary state for Northern mind
are I like many other members of this
house found this to be an unacceptable
State of Affairs the storm won't break
not only ends that but ensures that
changes to rules and regulations have
both the consent of both communities
asserting a fundamental principle of the
Belfast Good Friday agreement
I'll happily give waiters on a little
gentleman here I'm I'm very grateful to
my right honorable friend who has made
this progress uh hugely possible through
his hard work does he agree with me that
wherever you're starting from by
comparing the Northern Ireland protocol
with the Windsor framework it is quite
clear to everyone that good progress has
been made and that it is an improvement
and that it is welcomed by most of the
communities in Northern Ireland very
strongly indeed and for that reason we
should be sporting it tonight
yes of course
thank the minister for giving way and
he's making a powerful case about
Democratic scrutiny in that Spirit then
will he also confirm in order to support
the Windsor agreement that he will use
his powers as the Secretary of State to
retain all the existing EU law that will
be deleted by the EU law bill by the end
of this year because the European Union
has written to us today to warn that if
he does not do that this agreement will
be in doubt it's not to do with the
storm or broke it is the existing
legislation that will be deleted by the
sunset Clause he has the power to retain
it is he going to to support this
legislation I I I'm afraid I've not seen
that later I do I know nothing of it and
I do believe that the retained EU law
bill is going to do a good job of work
for the whole of the United Kingdom
I'm going to give way to my Olive friend
for rally I'll take my who's on their
feet I thank Texas State I fear today we
will respectfully have to free to
disagree but he has described the break
on multiple occasions including in BBC
interviews as a veto
given that if Stormont pulls it
UK ministers may still not exercise the
break in exceptional circumstances so
it's down to ministerial Fiat and also
given that even if they do the EU can
object and it's referred to Independent
arbitration where the UK could lose
that is a route to arbitration isn't it
that is not a veto will he accept that
um
it is a veto two it is a route to
arbitration and three it removes any
element of the ecj being relevant in
this decision so I think we've actually
delivered on some of the things that the
honorable gentleman and I have
campaigned on over the years gentlemen
over there I am grateful in respect of
grounds for seeking to apply the break
in response to a written question to the
foreign office the Parliamentary in the
secretary of state is replied as to
exports to Northern Ireland through the
ports of holyhead he said the Green Lane
is open to all UK businesses where they
import or sell Goods that are not
ultimately destined for the EU markets
this includes good traveling from Wales
to Northern Ireland in transit through
the Republic of Ireland using the
transit position procedure can you
confirm that this is indeed the case and
the elaborates now mobile how would that
procedure will actually work so stay um
I I thank you for his question which I I
don't think I heard the book um
completely but the Green Lane will be
open for goods traveling into Northern
Ireland for consumption in Northern
Ireland there is a red lane that is for
goods that are going into the Republic
itself misheard The Honorable
gentleman's question
um I'll write to him and clarify if
that's okay
yes I'm gonna give away to The Honorable
gentleman
great go to the Secretary of State why
do EU laws apply to businesses in
Northern Ireland under this agreement
that are not trading with the EU how
many EU laws apply and why don't we see
a list of them Thursday it's it's less
than three percent it preserves access
for Northern Ireland businesses who are
to the single market and uh as
um I detailed yesterday I listed a whole
host of the different areas by which uh
this uh laws EU laws are disapplied
um in uh Northern I'm going to take two
more interventions one from the
gentleman there and one from a form of
Secretary of State I'm extremely uh
grateful to the executive State
um he's of course right to say that any
political political entity within a
wider economic structure should have a
say or some way of expressionism Express
expressing his fee relation to the rules
and regulations of that economic
structure with that in mind will the
British government be bringing forward a
CNN Hollywood break when it comes to the
UK internal Market
break stops and gives total control to
the assembly in Northern Ireland on any
new EU law or regulation and secondly
that this deal has made huge strides
from seed potatoes to vat to state aid
to customs to all aspects of the
protocol that we in this house have
debated for so long
I I have to agree with my right
honorable friend
um and I think what I best should do now
Mr Speaker is go continue with this so I
can explain this all to the house
because the break is triggered if 30
members of the legislative assembly in a
moment if I may
um from two parties object to an
amending rule or regulation these mlas
can be from the same Community
designation so they can in theory and in
practice come from two unionist parties
or indeed two nationalist parties the
exercise of the break will require no
other process and no vote in the
assembly once the break has been pulled
the law will automatically be disapplied
in Northern Ireland after two weeks
the EU could challenge only challenge
the use of the Breakthrough
International arbitration after the law
had been suspended where the bar to
overturn it would be exceptionally High
the storm in a moment if I may
the storm up break is one of the most
significant changes that my right
honorable friend the Prime Minister has
secured is a robust change that gives
the United Kingdom a veto over Dynamic
alignment with EU rules
but just as importantly Mr Mr Speaker
the regulations we are debating today
put the democratically elected
representatives of the people of
Northern Ireland in the driving seat
when it comes to whether and when that
veto will be used I'll happily give away
to The Honorable gentleman in fact I
thank the sacredist dear for giving way
could he answer very clearly that's one
simple question
isn't it the case that every single
vehicle a lorry vehicle that will depart
the port of carne Ryan to Northern
Ireland will have to have customs
declaration papers for every product on
that vehicle and is it right that one
vehicle traveling from one part of the
United Kingdom to another part of the
United Kingdom continues to be treated
in that way
those Vehicles will be using the trusted
Trader service 21 fields of information
mostly Auto populated which would mean
no certificates needed from vets or from
any uh uh per person I think the
honorable gentleman I'm afraid it is I
think I'm right earlier gentleman
um I'll happily give way to uh my
original friend I I'm I'm grateful to
him for giving way when he appeared
before the European scrutiny committee
yesterday
um our ad honorable friend promised to
deliver the list of the three percent of
the EU laws he says will remain as a
consequence of this process can you
please tell us where that list is
and I I did give that the majority of
that list uh in uh the course of that
program and I did say I would write to
The Honorable gentleman which I will do
of course Mr Speaker the old protocol
did have some measures that were aimed
at giving it Democratic legitimacy the
UK did have a vote over any new laws
that the EU wanted to add to the
protocol but that veto did not extend to
Amendments of laws that were already
there and crucially there was no role
for the northern assembly in deciding
whether and when to use that veto and of
course it contained the Democratic
consent mechanism an important means of
giving the assembly the right to end the
application of Articles 5 to 10 of the
old protocol those measures were
important and the Windsor framework
maintains them but they were not in
themselves enough to address the
Democratic deficit
I'll have to give away tomorrow I'm
grateful to my right I'm a friend for
giving away and I wonder if we can just
clarify something for me he's spoken
about the green channel for goods
movements from Great Britain into
Northern Ireland
is it the case and this is a genuine
question as I understand it the Northern
Ireland economy produces about 77
billion pounds worth of goods of which
65 billion go to the rest of Great
Britain
is it not the case though that
everything manufactured in Northern
Ireland would have to meet EU standards
even if it's going to the rest of the UK
yes we're very specifically clear that
we are maintaining it's basically three
percent of EU law in all nine which is
the bare minimum to maintain Northern
Ireland's access to the single Market
which just about every business I've
spoken to in Northern Ireland and have
made representations is delighted to be
maintaining
um and indeed I've been lobbied by
individual members around uh from
Northern Ireland to to actually have
this maintenance of access to both the
UK Market the fifth largest economy uh
in in the world and indeed the EU market
for goods I'll happily give way to my
right and wolf friend I'm grateful to my
right honorable friend and I fully we
support what he's done here I think the
Prime Minister and the whole of the
Northern Ireland team have done a great
job and does he agree with me that this
Windsor agreement enables a huge
opportunity in Northern Ireland not just
to be a Precious part of our United
Kingdom but also to be the target of
enormous amounts of foreign direct
investment coming into Northern Ireland
because it will have the advantage of
being an integral part of the United
Kingdom but having open access to EU
markets as well
and by maintaining that three percent of
EU law she helps answer the question but
my right honorable friend for Litchfield
uh posed as I say there'll be a binding
obligation in domestic law on ministers
to pull the break when a valid
notification
um is provided by 30 mlas and actually
just to address these these regulations
will add a new Democratic scrutiny
schedule to the northern 1998 to codify
this break in domestic law the the UK
government must let me repeat that Mr
Speaker must notify the EU when a valid
notification of the break has been
provided by mlas this is an important
new function for members of the assembly
it's vital they exercise this new
function with the right information and
expertise after Consulting with Northern
Ireland parties these regulations
provide for a standing committee of the
assembly to provide to properly
scrutinize the relevant rules
Mr Speaker I'll have to take it yeah I'm
very grateful to
giving way and because I entering this
vote today as a recognition of The Wider
package and voting for it with the
government on the issue of the Democrats
strictly committee this is a due to the
assembly it will require a lot of
resources as will the the necessity of
engaging with Brussels in terms of the
developers of new law for fresh
principles will the secretary have a
conversation with the assembly write the
potential for new resources to make sure
you can actually do its job fully in
that regard and I very much look forward
to having that conversation with a fully
functioning assembly and executive uh Mr
Speaker someone describe as a consultant
this is a consultative role for mlas it
is not it's a robust power for mlas to
stop the application of amended EU rules
a power that neither the UK government
nor the European Union can override
provided the conditions in the framework
are met some have claimed I'm going to
keep going for a bit if I may please
um some have claimed that the EU must
have some means of blocking the break
these regulations demonstrate Mr Speaker
that this process is entirely one for
the United Kingdom the process is firmly
and unambiguously within strand one of
the Belfast Good Friday agreement there
is no role for any institutions outside
the United Kingdom whether that be the
EU or anyone else to determine whether
the break is pulled it will be a choice
of the UK alone its Sovereign government
alongside elected mlas whether the break
is pulled some also claim Mr Speaker
that the government might simply ignore
the break these regulations make clear
that the government has no discretion
here mlas cannot be ignored valid
notifications of the break must be
notified to the European Union
the government's actions will in a
moment I will if government's actions
will be subject to all the Normal Public
Law principles that attach to decision
making
after the avoidance of doubt the
regulations are clear that the prospects
of any remedial measures by the EU
cannot be a relevant factor in the
government's determination Mr Speaker
it is enough
it is not enough to Simply allow mlas to
temporarily halt the application of a
rule but then allow the United Kingdom
to the United Kingdom government to
Simply override them when the joint
committee decides whether the rule
should be permanently disapplied so
these regulations go much further and
provide a clear robust directive role to
determine whether the government should
use its veto or not
unless there is cross community support
in the assembly ministers will be
legally prohibited from accepting an
amended or new EU law which creates a
regulatory border between Northern
Ireland and the rest of the United
Kingdom except in exceptional
circumstances and let me be clear
exceptional circumstances means just
that the threshold for that exception is
unbelievably High and a minister
invoking exceptional circumstances must
be able to defend that decision robustly
and in line with normal Public Law
principles and what's more a minister
must account to Parliament where they
have concluded that exceptional
circumstances apply or where they
consider that a measure would not create
a regulatory border
this represents one of the strongest
statutory constraints on the exercise of
ministerial functions under a treaty
ever codified in our domestic law I have
to give away thank you secularistic for
giving away will you just confirm to the
house if there is no storm and will
there be a storm and break
without this break cannot even start to
be a thing until Stormont goes back and
the executive functions missed
I'm happy to give away to him sorry I'm
very grateful to the Secretary of State
for giving away thank him for setting
out the way this break will operate
would he join me in urging those
considering these proposals before the
house today to note that this is
something that for many years people
said was impossible an application to
stop the ratchet of EU law and to keep
Northern Ireland in the Union
yeah so I absolutely agree with my
honorable friend I was told um this
would be an impossible ask as well and
throughout my time in the European
Parliament and indeed as chairman of an
illustrious body of MPS in in this place
I never thought this would be achievable
and yet this government has managed to
achieve it finally Mr Speaker as with
many internet any International
agreement the if the EU has considered
um actually before I go Mr Speaker these
regulations could scarcely make things
clearer the overwhelming presumption is
that unless the assembly says yes the
government must say no
finally Mr Speaker and as with any
International agreement if the EU
considers that the UK is improperly
pulled the break it may choose to
initiate a dispute but we need to be
clear that any dispute could only arise
after the rules have been disapplied in
Northern Ireland and the resolution of
that dispute would be for an arbitration
panel the European court of justice
would have no role in resolving that
dispute
Mr Speaker these regulations make the
case for a functioning for the
functioning devolved institutions in
Northern Ireland even more compelling
these measures will become operable only
when the institutions are restored
denying the people of Northern Ireland
will not only deny them the basic right
to an effective stable government but
will also deny them the full Democratic
input into the laws that apply to
Northern Ireland and that denial cannot
be justified
Mr Speaker these regulations give
domestic legal effect to this Democratic
Safeguard and restore the UK's
sovereignty we should consider carefully
how we vote on this measure without this
measure Northern Ireland would continue
to have full and automatic Dynamic
alignment with EU Goods rules with no
say for the Northern Ireland assembly
and no veto on amending or replacing
those measures that is an intolerable
situation Mr Speaker and I urge all
honorable and right honorable members to
vote to end that full and automatic
Dynamic alignment I therefore commend
this order to the house and beg to move
the question is I was on the order paper
I know call The Shadow Secretary of
State Peter Kyle yeah yeah thank you Mr
Speaker
the right honorable gentleman the member
for Hobart and Saint Patrick's St
pancreas the leader of my party said in
January that any protocol deal struck
between the UK government and the EU
would by definition mean real progress
in mitigating the problems caused by the
original deal
that they negotiated
he pledged that in these circumstances
labor would support such a deal it is a
pledge that we will be honoring today
so whereas the government has once again
been distracted by rebellion and
infighting within their own party
thanks to the labor party they can be
sure that the national interests will be
served today
of course I'm grateful to The Honorable
gentleman for giving me because he
actually makes a very important Point
here for the last quarter essentially
the house has proceeded in relation to
the peace process in Northern Ireland
and today is about the peace process
let's be quite clear about that on the
basis of by craft design or non-partisan
politics for that reason my party will
also be joining him undergovernment in
the lobbies tonight
yeah
I'm grateful for the right honorable
gentleman's intervention and taking the
similar position and coming to a similar
view as a labor party as a Scottish MP I
should also want to express my uh
sympathies with the incident which is
unfolding in Edinburgh with a ship which
is capsized and is injuring will be
believe 15 or more people so our
sympathies are with with him and the
people of Scotland today
uh the the government has said that the
vote today is the main vote on The
Windsor framework it's the main vote
that this house will get my speech will
focus on why labor supports the deal
overall but I will also begin on the
Stormont break itself which is the
subject of the regulations that this
this SI puts in place today
the Democratic deficit was also was
always one of the hardest parts of the
protocol deal to reconcile of course
businesses and most people in Northern
Ireland want to continue access to the
European market as well as the internal
Market but the cost of this access was
having no say in the rules which had to
be followed the storm won't break will
give Representatives a say once devolved
government is restored it is impossible
to argue that this is not an improvement
on the current situation
30 mlas from two parties will be able to
trigger the break
but I think just just as important is
the new Committee in the assembly that
will scrutinize new laws and which will
affect Northern Ireland there are
understandable concerns about how the
break will work in practice but the best
way of stress testing this can only be
done through experience and you can only
get the experience by restoring Stormont
getting Northern Ireland's devolved
government back up and running is what
we all want to see I know also it's what
the dup members want to see too
I want to State the obvious before going
further the economy in Northern Ireland
has huge potential the economy in
Northern Ireland is doing well the Prime
Minister rather eloquently explained why
during his last visit to Northern
Ireland he didn't need to because
everyone who lives there or runs a
business already knows but the challenge
is posed by the protocol go much deeper
than the market access and that's what
needs most attention join these
torturous period of renegotiation and I
give way to my older fans I thank my
honorable friend for giving me and I
think he was right to acknowledge that
there were legitimate concerns that
unionism had around the operation of the
protocol would he agree with me though
that anyone looking at this objectively
would say objectively would say that
those have been addressed both by the EU
and the UK government but further to
that the fundamental point is that
businesses and Saint Helens would give
their right arms to have the
opportunities that Northern Ireland has
Logistics medical manufacturing and
agriculture to have access to those two
Market yeah
I'm grateful for my honorable friends
intervention I'm also pleased that he
recognized the legitimate concerns that
the dup have but yes I think all of us
right across the United Kingdom want to
see devolved Administration in Northern
Ireland up and running that's what the
purpose of this whole torturous process
has been and hopefully we can get a
reckon we can get resolved uh soon I
give way to The Honorable gender right
on General for work so what is the point
of rushing through a vote on this
protocol when it is the protocol on the
agreement behind it that prevents
Stormont meeting which means the
protocol would never be used
well he makes the argument for why you
should have voted against the protocol
in the first place we on this side did
oppose a protocol when it was imposed he
voted for it now there are lots of
people on that side Mr Speaker Mr Deputy
speaker that I listened to with great
interest because they often contribute a
lot of thoughtful insight into the way
we debate but let's just reflect on what
the honorable the right old member for
wokingham said in the run-up to the
brexit referendum the promises that he
made to this country this all came from
his website because I read it with great
interest one
there will be more growth in the economy
two it'll rebuild our Fisheries three
food will be cheaper four our power will
be cheaper
we will have fewer unhelpful regulations
well if that's the case we wouldn't be
here debating this today would we six we
will get a U.S trade deal and seven our
balance of payments will improve there
are many people who should be
contributing to this debate in a
thoughtful way he I'm afraid is not one
of them
the challenges posed by the protocol go
much deeper than Market access and
that's what's needed most attention
joiners torturous process of
renegotiation
the unionist concerns were mostly
twofold firstly there were impediments
to the flow of goods traveling across
the Irish sea
some products and shipment some in a
moment some products and ship and
shipments were more effective than
others having a disruptive effect on
Supply chains and the ability of
retailers to keep their stores stocked
in a manner familiar to pre-protocol
Shoppers Shoppers this of course leads
to the second source of concern which is
the existential impact that these
impediments have are to the free flow of
goods within the United Kingdom and what
that poses for unionism I give way I'm
grateful to The Honorable member for
giving way would the honorable member
agree with me that the government has
made tremendous progress with this
Windsor framework in terms of Veterinary
and sanitary and phytosanitary measures
and what has been achieved with the
securing of human medicines long term
and the direction of travel for securing
Veterinary medicines after up until the
grace period ends shows that what can be
achieved through dialogue and it really
shows to us all that we should be
strongly supporting this framework deal
it does indeed show that negotiating and
talking rather than rowing delivers more
but it also shows that you should think
very carefully about what you vote for
in the first place it is right it is a
right enshrined in treaty that anyone in
Northern Ireland who wants to associate
themselves as British should be able to
do so without impediment I understand
this of course I do
if produce made in Sussex faced checks
on the border with Hampshire I would
have something to say about it and I've
also asked myself this if the protocol
checks were taking place between Ireland
and Northern Ireland instead of the
Irish sea would nationalist communities
be demanding action today I believe they
would
so demand for Action is warranted
it is based on real concerns not
confected ones so the mystery to me has
always been why the government took so
long to act why wait until devolved
authorities had collapsed before seeming
to Care by the time I was appointed to
this job the dup had been voicing
concerns about the protocol for well
over six months
they were ignored
a month before I was appointed the right
animal member for the lagam valley had
published an article calling for article
16 to be triggered it was met with
silence
then in February the executive was
collapsed followed four months later by
the assembly in all that time there was
no visits by the prime minister no
meetings with party leader leaders
either in Northern Ireland or in Downing
Street
not a single statement to this house
as a result of this neglect and believe
me it is neglect
we are now faced with two problems the
first is solving the technical issues
created as a direct result of the
original protocol negotiated by that
government and voted for by every single
person sitting on those benches that
protocol I remind the house was created
negotiated and hailed as a great deal
for Britain by this government at the
time
unless we forget it was voted for by
every single member on those benches
including those Affiliated by the ear
through the ERG faction secondly that
period of neglect created a political
problem that this government is paying
the price for right here today put
simply when the dup were expressing
their concerns over the protocol from
within the devolved institutions they
were ignored by the government in
Westminster when they collapse those
institutions they were rewarded with the
prime minister's Prime ministerial visit
and ultimately the renegotiation of the
protocol
the message from government couldn't be
to sit it couldn't be clearer
the learned behavior of dealing with
this government is that if you act
functionally within the devolved
Administration you are ignored of course
but if you act fight if you act outside
of the administration you are
unignorable
of course in this period the other
Northern Ireland parties have been
denied their place within the government
as well through no fault of their own
in just one moment
so if you disrupt an act outside of the
structures of government
you get all the attention in the world
you even get the Prime Minister
traveling abroad on your behalf to
renegotiate a deal with hitherto been
told was unrenegotiable
I've been wait for the honorable General
from Stanford I think this element is
not only neglect or ignorance does the
uh shuttle Minister recognize that Tony
Blair the former leader of the labor
party said you can't move forward
without unionist participation in this
process in this agreement uh this
framework Bernie Ahern also with a a
former an instrument and the peace
process also said you can't ignore
unionism agree when it comes to moving
forward unionism cannot be ignored in
our point of view it has to be covered
to the whole issue of how we find a
process to go forward
I'm very grateful for his intervention
and I'm very grateful for the
opportunity to have the exchange between
us and it gives me the opportunity to
say that I can only speak for the labor
party I can speak for myself as a shadow
Secretary of State and that is that his
party and no party in Northern Ireland
will ever be ignored by this by this
party or a future labor government but
also as I'm about to explain that you
will be most rewarded and you'll have
most attention and have most agency in
politics in political life right across
the United Kingdom from a position
within the devolved authorities so I do
understand his point uh Tony Blair and
others were right but uh but these are
all leaders who gave the attention to
the dep and every other party at the
point at which they needed it they
didn't wait until the evolution had
collapsed before paying you and them and
their parties the respect that they are
owed and due
I will give way
Mr Speaker to give the shadow Minister
some credit he is excellent at
articulating the problem but what's his
solution
I'm very grateful because we'll be
getting to it and of course part uh he
he he he also he also well it's it's
interesting that members there want me
to speed up but they keep intervening so
uh I'll I'll get through to speech if
you allow me to get to it but he makes
uh the the most blinding the obvious
Point here my party will be voting in
unlimity today it is his party that is
getting in the way of getting this
across the line because it is his party
it is split over how to vote on the
issue before us today we're acting in
the National interest they are Riven
with division
so people like me aspire to government
because we want to deliver positive
change but the dup now have to ask
themselves because of the way they've
been treated by this government
would a return to government mean
relinquishing power
this inversion of the very principle of
government this absurdity is a direct
consequence of the manner in which
Northern Ireland has been treated by
this government and subsequent
conservative administrations over the
last 13 years and I want to be clear to
members who represent communities in
Northern Ireland in what they can expect
from a future labor government to answer
the point of the last intervention so
let me reassure them that we haven't
forgotten the lessons of 25 years ago
and the tough years following the peace
deal to me those lessons are first that
leadership matters Tony Blair's first
visit outside of London as prime
minister was to Belfast he visited five
times in his first year as primit as
Premier he didn't neglect Northern
Ireland and nor will my writable friend
the member for Hoban and some pancreas
second in a moment second work towards a
strong trusting relationship with the
Irish government because when our two
countries work together closely it eases
the anxiety that some people in Northern
Ireland feel regarding their Irish or
British identities as well as creating
the conditions for economic progress
across the island of Ireland
third we need to have the same ambition
for Northern Ireland as we do for every
other part of our Union I give way
The Honorable gentleman for giving way
and I note what he's saying and he's
absolutely right the agreement 25 years
ago would not have been possible without
the the sacrifices and the statesmanship
of so many others but would he
acknowledge that actually it was John
Major and his government that started
that process and that this isn't a part
of political matter this is something
that this house should be proud of
uh firstly I thank her for her time as
Secretary of State for Northern Ireland
as well and I readily acknowledge that
many many people made peace possible in
in Northern Ireland 25 years ago we in
this house will have the opportunity to
debate these issues in a general debate
coming up uh and there will be plenty of
opportunity over in in Belfast as
dignitaries from across the world come
in to celebrate the great achievement of
that time uh John Major of course laid
the foundations and I think at the time
and and subsequently all labor leaders
including Tony Blair at the time paid a
great uh respect to the contribution
that he made
um if I start listing the names of
everyone then we'll be here for a very
long time and indeed third we need to
have the same ambition for Northern
Ireland as we do for every other part of
the union for example it is not good
enough to roll out home heating support
months after citizens in every other
part of the UK have received their
support fourth we should aspire to to
build respect among communities and be a
voice for all communities here in
Westminster the last Labor government
positioned the UK as an honest broker
for all of Northern Ireland and so will
the next and finally Mr Speaker labor
will never give up on Northern Ireland
however insurmountable the challenges
might seem those involved in the
negotiations 25 years ago have plenty of
stories of frustration and moments of
hopelessness but perseverance is
rewarded it was then and it will be
again today and into the future it
always is in Northern Ireland
while the steel is not perfect it is an
improvement
so the interest of Northern Ireland and
the rest of our country we will be
voting for it today thank you thank you
very much as you can see there's a great
deal of interest in this debate so can I
please ask people when they did it make
their contributions to make it short
please serve as many people can get in
Julian Smith
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I welcome
the debate and the vote today and the
Windsor framework has my full support I
also welcome the fact that the labor
party lib Dem party and almost the s p I
think are supporting the government and
the conservative party today those of us
who have followed this issue closely
probably never expected to be here
debating a renegotiation of the treaty
uh itself and it's Testament to the
prime minister's determination that out
of the Secretary of State the foreign
secretary and others that this focus and
through this Focus they've been able to
achieve that
um as someone also who's been slightly
traumatized by brexit votes over the
years
um I'm also delighted that this is the
end chapter
and notwithstanding further improvements
and changes I think this chapter is one
we're probably all delighted to be
ending
[Laughter]
standing
for you said may I suggest that still
this remains unfinished business as
regards I'll leave in the European Union
some people have never finished Mr
deputies some things never change but I
I paid tribute to my writable friend for
his focus and continued monomaniacal
focus on this issue I want to also
acknowledge the work done by honorable
members in Northern Ireland although
we'll be in different uh division
lobbies today I believe the right
honorable member for Lagoon Valley spoke
powerfully about the Democratic deficit
and the need for cross-community
safeguards which are now at the heart of
the storm won't break as one of Michelle
banu's top advisors said that the
secretary of state has just told us
there has actually been a big victory
for the Democratic unionist Party The
Honorable member for upper Barn worked
um harder than anybody else to finally
fix the issue of seed potatoes for her
farming constituents and The Honorable
members for North down foil and South
Belfast have all engaged closely with
businesses Northern Ireland Enterprises
to find practical Solutions I believe
that the huge progress has been achieved
and we now need to maximize the
potential for Northern Ireland to become
one of the most attractive places in to
invest in in the UK
I want to finish briefly by talking
about the union the greater strength we
have in securing Northern Ireland's
place in the union is the majority of
people in Northern Ireland who support
it
we must cherish nurture and expand that
support and consent at every opportunity
yeah recent polling has shown there is
huge support across Northern Ireland
above 70 for the Windsor framework and
for solving this issue and particularly
cross-community support for the access
it provides to both the UK and EU
markets
I believe if we can Bank the winds in
this deal and secure over time stable
power sharing
then we can look forward to decades and
Decades of overwhelming support for
Northern Ireland remaining an integral
part of the United Kingdom and that was
a three-minute contribution from a
former secretary of state so I'm sure
if we can all follow that we'll get a
lot of people in Richard Thompson
thank you Mr Deputy speaker perhaps I
should begin by addressing the remarks
made just there by the right honorable
member for Skipton and Ripon when he
said that he thought the SNP was almost
there ready to support him uh support
this I can say to him he's almost right
because we will in fact be uh supporting
uh this this agreement we welcome it and
we will be voting in favor uh this this
evening uh certainly the the mechanism
has set out in the SI provides what
looks at first glance like a a
reasonably effective uh means of
scrutiny with installment although I do
have to say that in terms of its
function as a break it's uh perhaps
questionable whether or not that break
Weaver is actually connected to anything
and only time will tell so in terms of
the good aspects we welcome at long last
the UK government has engaged
constructively over our prolonged period
with EU Partners to come to an agreement
which improves the the protocol we
welcome that the protocol bill has been
left abandoned as it always should have
been aware in the prospect of a
catastrophic series of tit-for-tat trade
reactions over the protocol which would
have been disastrous but all parts of
the UK and the task now is for ministers
to start repairing some of the damage
that's been caused in the intervening
period now from our perspective in
Scotland this uh well it certainly
restores access for Scottish producers
to the northern Irish Market it still
leaves us deprived of equivalent access
to the European single market so in that
respect uh it's not my natural
disposition to be a party pooper in any
way as I'm sure the house would agree
but this only serves to make an already
poor situation slightly less bad and
there are a number of questions that
still need to be asked about how the UK
government will continue to try and
improve trade conditions for other
devolved nations in the UK whether the
government can provide Clarity over the
how the port of care and Ryan will
operate and what infrastructure is did
with our cows and sheep being
transported between Northern Ireland and
Scotland can qualify for the Green Lane
and how the UK government is in more
broad terms going to tackle the food
security crisis that affects us all now
occasionally in politics you'll get uh
you're you're blessed with a rare
flasher Candor we had one in the budget
speech last week when the chancellor
said to Greater claim from these benches
that Independence is always better than
dependence
but we also had it from the the Prime
Minister when he went across to Northern
Ireland to excel as he saw the benefits
of the steel now I don't know if the
Prime Minister thought that uh just
because he was seeing it in Northern
Ireland that uh nobody would be able to
hear what it was over on Great Britain
and particularly in Scotland when he had
to say but here described Northern
Ireland under this uh this framework as
would be the the world's most exciting
economic zone because of access to both
GB and EU markets he also went on to say
that this very special position made
Northern Ireland an incredibly
attractive place to invest in fact it
was no less than the world's most
exciting economic zone and just to make
sure that he doesn't feel left out the
right honorable member for High Wycombe
also said that what an extraordinary
opportunity for Northern Ireland dual
access to both markets
well of course this very special
position is precisely part of the
entirety of the UK had private brexit
now I certainly Mr Deputy speaker do not
Grudge one iota that lose benefits for
Northern Ireland I just wonder why
members opposite whatever view they take
on this have been so utterly determined
to deprive those benefits to the rest of
us
William cash give us Deputy speaker uh
Mr Speaker Mr Deputy speaking I believe
in the real Union of the United Kingdom
and the sovereignty of its Parliament
here at Westminster
article one and two of the protocol
clearly State the principle of consent
for Westminster and then territorial
Integrity of the United Kingdom is
fundamental
consent and veto are different things
we have left the EU and we have passed
section 38 the guarantee of the
sovereignty of the United Kingdom
Parliament and yet
all laws passed before we left in
relation to the single Market still
apply to and subjugate
the people of Northern Ireland to the EU
but not to the rest of the UK there is
no such thing as Northern Ireland
sovereignty
there is only constitutional Westminster
sovereignty and I'm afraid I do not
recognize the expression practical
sovereignty used by the Secretary of
State in this debate and the letter he
wrote to the joint committee chairman on
Saturday instruments of the 20th of
March
why should two million Northern Ireland
citizens and voters for Westminster be
treated differently from say the two
million people from Birmingham Liverpool
or Manchester
of course and I think the young
virginity is making a powerful speech
and obviously he's a subject matter
expert and I know he has passionate
views on this um but listening to him
the the phrase that comes to mind it's a
German one I'm afraid it's pathological
reality takes vibrant it needs a
pathological denial of reality the the
simple fact is that live reality in
Birmingham Manchester is entirely
different we aren't against another
National border we don't need to have
some form of alignment with um with a
neighbor for the uh Freeman to goods and
services there's not a situation where
they for example a single I think it's
only a single milk processing plant on
the island of Ireland though there has
to be some sort of practical uh
recognition of the difficulties and the
reality
well unfortunately the heading of the
statue instrument was discovered we're
discussing in this motion today it says
constitutional law and I'm very sorry
I'd have to say that what the honorable
gentleman said and it's some references
to pathological something rather I'm
afraid makes absolutely no sense in
relation to constitutional law which is
that we in this country operate a rule
of law and a constitutional law which
confers the sovereignty of of to
Westminster Parliament which includes
the people of Birmingham Manchester
Liverpool and Northern Ireland and
should do so equally yeah so since
brexit Mr Deputy speaker over 640 laws
which we see each week in the European
scrutiny committee which I chair have
been passed already for Northern Ireland
by the EU Council of ministers behind
closed doors
in Brussels by majority vote without
even a transcript can we imagine laws
being passed in this country
in Westminster without Hansard without a
transcript and by majority of eight it's
unthinkable
of course I can great very grateful uh
for the honorable member for giving away
of course I think if memory serves me
right he did vote for the protocol that
didn't have a storm and break and had
far more checks and that could explain
why he's voting against this well very
simply because we agreed that we were
going to bring in the Northern Ireland
protocol bill I'll come on to that in a
minute that is the difference that's
what would have dealt with the situation
so we in we we in the rest of the UK
have left the EU and have done have been
subjected to our own laws not those of
the EU for the past as they were in the
for the last 50 years this as I've said
to the right honorable gentleman it
remains unfinished business
pre-brexit single Market legislation
continues in Northern Ireland
the Northern Ireland protocol bill
dealt with the unacceptable imposition
of EU laws but this bill is now being
disposed of to my very grave concern
although it was passed in this house by
a majority of 72 on third reading and
most of them are going to say are
vulnerable members who are here today on
our side of the house anyway voted for
it
The Windsor framework does not
effectively disappoint EU law as such in
for example the Customs regime because
this Falls within the legal competence
of the EU relation to Goods indeed if
the UK purports to use its so-called
veto in relation to this question of the
Stormont break the EU will be able to
get around this sooner or later in
respect to the green Lanes a main vote
for territory measures I'm afraid I'm
not impressed by the expression
exceptional circumstances words mean
what you choose them to mean said Humpty
Dumpty the question is who is to
remastered that is all and I believe
firmly that would be the European Union
in fact one of my sadnesses about this
whole business here today is that there
really was a need for proper time to
discuss in consultation with the
government alternative legal arguments
there are papers that have been produced
in the last 48 hours and over the last
few weeks there are blogs there are
commentaries by distinguished lawyers
which quite clearly demonstrate that the
arguments that are presented by the
government are not those which are
agreed by other eminent lawyers and this
point of law as well appoint as well as
a point of fact and as to the question
of democratic consent and the inadequacy
of the storm won't break I'm sure that
this will be addressed by the dup
members today this is as important to
all of us as the main principle of the
Union
the procedures have been rushed and I
simply cannot accept that it is right
for a statutory instrument to approved
in this house today when there is not
yet a legal decision in the withdrawal
agreement joint committee until Friday
so we're here furthermore I now hear
that the House of Lords itself which is
part of the joint committee is not going
to consider the statue instruments until
Wednesday the 29th of March
which is after the withdrawal agreement
joint committee sits so the government
in seeking approval of this stature
instrument today is not doing it in
synchronization with the House of Lords
and I find this manifestly
unsatisfactory
I am deeply concerned too that these
procedures are not following the
criteria of standing order 151 of the
joint committee on statutory instruments
and I do think that the chairman if I
may say with great respect that the
chairman of the joint committee on
Saturday instruments who is a member of
this house for Mortal should really be
here today to explain their position
I was surprised to see a letter from the
Secretary of State to the chairman of
that joint committee on statutory
instruments dated 20th of March in which
the Secretary of State in which I
certainly will
I'd like to thank him for giving ways
one of the few members of this house was
born and raised in Northern Ireland can
I make it very clear that this is not
about his correspondence but about the
future of the people of Northern Ireland
the vast majority of whom support the
Windsor framework the business Community
Support the ruins of framework they
believe that this is a much better deal
negotiated by the Prime Minister than
they ever thought possible the people of
Northern Ireland and indeed the people
of the UK need to move on and focus on
more important things thank you
I mean it's not and this is really very
time limited the debate has to finish at
21 minutes past two I'm just about to
conclude by saying that this is about
the rule of law and it's about
constitutional law as well as the very
fair points that The Honorable lady has
just made I don't doubt the importance
to the stability of Northern Ireland I
have taken a great interest in these
matters for many many years but I will
insist that the Constitutional position
is not reflected by the arrangements in
this Windsor agreement and I would
simply make this as a final point the
proof of the pudding as the deputy
speaker will be in the eating so Jeffy
Donaldson yeah thank you Mr Deputy
speaker and I will try to be brief but
you will appreciate that there is a lot
we would like to say today in very
limited time and these regulations which
we are debating today uh known to many
as the storm and break but they do touch
on many very important legal and
political matters and can I at the
outset thank the Prime Minister the
Secretary of State and others for their
continued engagement with my party for
the efforts that they have made although
at this stage we may differ on our views
in relation to the Windsor framework I'm
not here to question the motivation of
ministers in seeking to make
improvements but they must and I hope
will continue to work with us and others
to get the further improvements that we
need to enable the restoration of the
world government in Northern Ireland and
to be clear uh Mr Deputy speaker I want
to see the restoration of devolved
government in Northern Ireland my party
is a party of devolution we believe that
delivering Effective Government for our
people is the best way forward working
alongside this house and this Parliament
and that is where we want to get to but
we've got to get it right and I Echo the
comments of The Honorable member for
stone about the rush to bring this
statutory instrument forward I have
written to the Joint Committee and
statutory instruments expressing my
concern that we haven't had adequate
time for scrutiny of this statutory
instrument but today the government has
indicated that we're not just dealing
with the S.I before us but this today is
also an indicative vote on The Windsor
framework itself and therefore it's
important that in my comments I reflect
not just on what the storm and break
does but where it fits in to that wider
Windsor framework
fundamentally for us Mr Deputy speaker
the problem with the Northern Ireland
protocol is the continued application of
EU law in Northern Ireland in
circumstances where it covers all
manufacturing of goods in Northern
Ireland regardless of whether those
goods are being sold in the United
Kingdom or sold to the European Union
and I repeat the statistics that I
quoted earlier at Northern Ireland
questions of all goods manufactured in
Northern Ireland the vast majority of
them some 65 billion pounds worth of
goods out of 77 billion manufactured are
sold in the United Kingdom and therefore
the solution must be proportionate to
the difficulty and the difficulty is the
eu's desire to protect its single market
and to maintain an open border on the
island of Ireland but the price for that
Mr Deputy speaker cannot be that
Northern Ireland businesses at
manufacturing goods for sale in the
United Kingdom are inhibited in many
ways from Trading within their own
market and so I say to the Secretary of
State that in relation to the Windsor
framework whilst undoubtedly
improvements have been made we have not
yet fully addressed this fundamental
problem which is the continued
application of EU law for the
manufacturing of all Goods in Northern
Ireland and we believe the real solution
here is similar to that which was
proposed in the Northern Ireland
protocol bill which is that where goods
are being sold in the United Kingdom
staying in the United Kingdom
United Kingdom law and standards apply
and where goods are being manufactured
by Northern Ireland businesses for sale
in the Republic of Ireland or any other
EU member State EU rules apply and thus
the solution we're looking for and the
Windsor framework does not deliver that
solution
I will give way to to thank my brother
my friend for giving away uh would he
agree that on the point he's made or any
other
improvements or changes that needs to be
made the best way to influence now is
for Stormont to return and for Stormont
to be the center of what I'm sure will
be ongoing uh improves and iterations in
this area
well I I I thank the right honorable uh
gentleman the former Secretary of State
for his continued interest in Northern
Ireland
and I say to him simply this
that my ministers in the Democratic
unionist party sat in Stormont for over
a year after the protocol was
implemented
and we plead it with the government as
the right honorable member the the
opposition spokesperson reminded the
house today we plead it with the
government to intervene to do something
to help us with the difficulties that
the protocol was creating and the
government did not act and I had to take
action and it was our action that
brought the EU back to the table and yes
we have made progress as a result of
that but more is needed what is the more
that is needed it is to deliver the
pledge given by the government in the
new decade new approach agreement to
protect Northern Ireland's place within
the internal Market of the United
Kingdom and whilst The Windsor framework
goes some way to doing that in relation
to the movement of goods from Great
Britain to Northern Ireland it does not
deal for example with the real potential
for Divergence between laws that apply
in Northern Ireland EU laws and laws
that apply in Great Britain UK laws
where the UK decides to change change
regulations that were formerly EU
regulations and there is a bill before
this house that will Fast Track and
significantly broaden the number of UK
laws that are going to be changed and
where EU laws disappoint and that
creates the potential for Divergence
between Northern Ireland and Great
Britain it harms our ability to trade
with Great Britain it harms the
Integrity of the internal Market of the
United Kingdom and The Windsor framework
doesn't address that problem and we need
it addressed so I say to the right
honorable member I want to see storm it
up and running but we need the
government to deliver the commitment it
made when he was the Secretary of State
to protect our place in the internal
Market of the United Kingdom I give way
very grateful and what do you also agree
that because the EU will have powers
over things like vat and state AIDS in
Northern Ireland it will also have
powers on a drag through basis over the
whole United Kingdom and doesn't the
whole United Kingdom need a veto
well I agree with the right honorable
gentleman and I say that that is why we
need a solution that enables the United
Kingdom government on this Parliament to
regulate the entirety of the United
Kingdom internal Market that is the
solution
um I am not saying that we're Northern
armed businesses trade with the EU EU
standards and rules should not apply I'm
saying we can allow for that but what I
am not accepting is a situation where
every business in my constituency must
comply with EU rules even if they don't
sell a single widget to the European
Union and that is wrong because it harms
our place in the internal Market of the
United Kingdom
the storm would break seeks to address
the Democratic deficit that I have
mentioned and to an extent it provides a
role for Stormwind to pull that break
when changes to EU law are occurring but
note it does not give us any ability to
deal with existing EU law that impacts
on all manufacturing in Northern Ireland
laws that have been applied without our
consent and therefore to that extent the
break cannot apply it applies to
amendments or to EU law or changes new
EU laws that are introduced and I also
note Mr Deputy speaker that in the
proposed Arrangements it is available to
the EU to take retaliatory action in the
event that the UK government applies a
veto to a new EU law now this is a
matter of concern to us in Northern
Ireland because
retaliatory action could bring could
come in a number of forms and could
include the suspension of Arrangements
in the Green Lane which would impact our
ability to bring goods from Great
Britain to Northern Ireland so we need
to be clear that it is wrong for the EU
to be able to intervene at that level in
the free flow of goods from one part of
the United Kingdom to the other and so I
highlight that issue as a real matter of
concern to us
this intervention so Jeffrey there is
now nine minutes and also when you
resume your seat I'm introducing a three
minute time limit to get as many people
in so please be recognizant of that
I'm very grateful Mr Deputy speaker I'm
a red honorable friend we'll know of the
exchange the Secretary of State and I
had yesterday at the European scrutiny
committee and the invitation given to
him to indicate that an article 18 of
the storm and break exceptional
circumstances old would preclude
a material consideration being the EU
retaliatory action that he has so
referred the secretary of state was
quick yesterday to agree with the
interpretation can I ask through my red
honorable friend to the Secretary of
State at least will consider reaffirming
the commitment that he was given
yesterday it features in article 14 it
does not feature article 16 but just to
be clear retaliate reaction would not
allow the the threat of a child traction
would not allow a secretary of state to
consider that as an exceptional
circumstances when exercising a beetle
well I think that that my honorable
friend for that intervention and I
welcomed what the Secretary of State
said yesterday uh that we must not allow
the threat of EU retaliatory action to
influence ministers in exercising their
powers under the storm and break I also
welcome the clear commitment that the
Prime Minister gave to me recently that
the application of this uh Power the
storm would break is entirely a matter
for the United Kingdom it is a strong
one issue under the terms of the Belfast
agreement and that does not involve a
rule for the Irish government in
relation to these matters and that's a
very important principle for us Mr
Deputy speaker the Prime Minister has
also indicated to uh to me that in this
process the the wishes of storm will be
respected but it I have made clear that
in exercising the storm would break we
are we are simply applying
um in in our terms uh the the
possibility the the potential of a veto
by the United Kingdom government on one
aspect of EU law this does not deal with
all of the problem and that's the
difficulty that we have the continued
application of EU law in Northern
Ireland is what creates the problem for
us in our ability to trade within the
internal Market of the United Kingdom as
I come to a conclusion Mr Deputy speaker
um I think it is important uh that the
the government of the United Kingdom
takes stock of where we are now
I understand that the uh the foreign
secretary is going to the Joint
Committee of the the UK EU joint
committee on Friday to sign off on the
Windsor framework and the indicative
vote taken today in this house will be
used as justification for doing so
what can I say to the Secretary of State
surely our shared objective here as was
espised by the former Secretary of State
earlier is to see the political
institutions in Northern Ireland restore
and therefore we need to continue
engaging with the government to get this
right my party is committed to doing
that we are committed to continue
working with the Secretary of State
working with the Prime Minister and that
has to be about
delivering on the commitment given to
protect Northern Ireland's place within
the internal Market of the United
Kingdom that where EU law is applied to
facilitate cross-border trade that it
does not impede our ability to trade
with the rest of our own country within
the internal Market of our own country
that is the bottom line for us and until
that is resolved I can't commit to the
government that we will restore the
political institutions it's what I want
to do but we need to get this right I
want Stormont restored on a sustainable
basis on a stable basis where there is
cross community consent and consensus
that does not exist at the moment
and therefore we need to see that
command consensus restored Mr Deputy
speaker for our part we will continue to
work intensively to solve these issues
doing so in the knowledge that what has
already been achieved has been because
we were not prepared to accept the
undermining of Northern Ireland's place
within the union of the United Kingdom
the economic Union of the United Kingdom
that's what we stand for that's what we
will fight for we want to get it right
we will work with the government to do
that three-minute limit Karen Bradley
very much Miss adaptive speaker now my
right humble friendly secretary of state
will know that I rarely rise to speak in
debates that he leads not because I
disagree with what he's doing but I
think it's important that predecessors
do not comment too often on their
successes work I know how hard the job
of Secretary of State of Northern
Ireland is but I Rise to stand today
because I support wholeheartedly what he
has achieved together with the Prime
Minister and I want to see this
structure instrument go through with an
overwhelming majority of this house
today
two weeks ago uh the British Irish
parliamentary assembly which I co-chair
met in Belfast to commemorate the 25th
anniversary of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement we met in the currently empty
assembly chamber of Stormont we met with
representatives from legislatures across
the islands that make up the British
Isles and we reflected on the leadership
that had been required in order to
deliver that deal 25 years ago
leadership that didn't take just a few
weeks leadership that took years and
years people making sacrifices going
above and beyond and being prepared to
recognize that no deal is perfect but
the combination of getting to the result
of that Belfast Good Friday agreement
for the people of Northern Ireland and
the people across these islands was so
significant that that sacrifice was
worth making of course I gave away I'm
very grateful apply right honorable
friend does she also agree that another
great virtue of this agreement which is
much to be commended is it enables us to
resolve those issues in a way which does
not need into breach of any of our
international law obligations as would
have been the case have we proceeded
with the northern line and protocol bill
that has got to be a win for the UK's
reputation as well as for the people of
Northern Ireland I agree heartedly with
my honorable friend he speaks with great
wisdom as he always does
um
one of the things that was clear to me
when I was Secretary of State for
Northern Ireland uh and did the job that
he now does is that leaving the European
Union without a deal would have been
devastating for Northern Ireland it
would have been devastating economically
and it would have been devastating for
Community cohesion and that was why I
wanted to find a way when I was in the
role and then subsequently to make sure
that there was a deal that we could all
get behind now we had a deal that saw
the whole of the United Kingdom leave
the EU together in a in in exactly the
same way that deal wasn't exceptional it
wasn't acceptable to that side of the
house and it wasn't acceptable to many
of my honorable and right honorable
friends I recognize that I acknowledge
why that was the case they felt it would
have meant to have been too close to the
European Union and I fully respect that
we then had a deal presented to us by
the former prime minister the right
honorable member for Uxbridge and South
ruislip now there were many many faults
with that deal but I really believed the
Prime Minister when he said that he
wanted me to vote for that deal that it
was important for the people of Northern
Ireland and I was prepared to do that
even though I knew that there would
result in checks on Goods on the Irish
sea even though that was clear from that
uh from that agreement but I was
prepared to do that because it's so
important and my prime minister asked me
to vote for it now we must remember that
when the Belfast Good Friday agreement
was drawn up and the Northern Ireland
agreement Act was enacted we and the
United Kingdom and north and Ireland
were both members of the EU so that
meant many of the issues did not have to
be codified we didn't have to set out
what happened to Goods traveling we
didn't have to set out rights because
those rights came from our joints but
both of us having membership at the EU
leaving the EU means that some of these
issues now need to be codified they can
only be done through negotiation they
can only be done by there being
accommodation made on both sides what
the Prime Minister has come back with
with the Windsor framework shows
enormous uh accommodation actually from
the EU side the storm of break is an
absolutely extraordinary thing for the
EU to agree to and people around the
world are looking at the what we have
achieved and congratulating the right
our writable friend the Prime Minister
for what he has achieved so I say to
this house
what is the alternative to the Windsor
framework what is it we think we're
going to get there is nothing better on
the table this is a significant move
forward and I urge my vulnerable and
right honorable friends to vote for it
Hillary Ben very much indeed Mr Deputy
speaker I must confess that when I read
the Windsor framework I was surprised
and pleasantly surprised because as the
Secretary of State told the house
earlier there are things in there I
didn't think the negotiation would
manage to achieve and it to the great
credit of the negotiators I would also
say it is to the great credit of the dup
that they have achieved so much in this
agreement
and
the EU has had to move a long way
and I think it is a very sensible
proposal because leaving the European
Union always confronted us with a choice
about what to do about the border
between Northern Ireland and the
Republic apart from those who say well
that's not my problem leave it to the EU
everybody knew that some arrangement had
to be put in place the result was the
protocol it didn't work the Windsor
framework I think provides a way forward
and the storm won't break in particular
answers the point that I've heard
members of the dup make in this house
about future EU legislation because the
break is available the second point I
want to make is to respond very directly
to the point the right honorable
gentleman for Lagoon Valley made about
existing EU law that continues to apply
in the European Union
many of that many of those bits of
legislation have applied in the European
Union in Northern Ireland in the United
Kingdom for years
for years have they impacted on the
ability of Northern Ireland businesses
to trade with the rest of the United
Kingdom no they have not and they apply
in Great Britain because of EU retained
law now the government has a choice when
it decides which of those bits of
retained law it wants to dispose of or
change through the EU retained law Bill
to what extent it wants to create
Divergence I suspect that by the time we
get to the end of this year many of
those pieces of legislation will still
be applying in Great Britain because
Divergence creates problems it's the
point that the former prime minister who
is in her place made in one of her her
speeches shortly after the referendum
she said Divergence results in us having
to make a choice and the final point I
want to make is that it is very striking
that businesses will take decisions for
themselves there was a recent example
the EU decided to reduce the amount of
permitted arsenic in baby foods
now what did manufacturers in Britain do
in response it didn't wait for the
government to say well we might or might
not follow suit they said henceforth we
will of course produce baby foods
matching the EU standard because they
want to continue to be able to sell
their products and ultimately businesses
will decide the standard that works for
them this is a very sensible measure I
congratulate the negotiators and I
really hope the house is going to vote
for it Sir Jeffrey Cox thank you Mr
Speaker I think we must avoid the danger
of hyperbole
and I hope I don't disappoint my
honorable friends on the front bench by
saying that I do not think we can
characterize this as the last word that
will ever be spoken on this subject but
it does represent
material and real progress and if I had
seen three years ago if my right
honorable friend and I had seen in 2019
a similar
flexibility on behalf of the European
Union
history might have turned out rather
differently
my right honorable friend the Prime
Minister has achieved considerable
things with this agreement no it is not
the last word yes it is true that to any
of those who prize the constitutional
principles my honorable friend for stone
has spoken of
it will always leave a lasting sense of
dissatisfaction
that there are certain rules that apply
in Northern Ireland that do not apply on
the mainland of Great Britain
but Northern Ireland is a special case
it was already recognized to be a
special case when the Good Friday
agreement was introduced
and when even then by the British Irish
agreement
the full and absolute sovereignty of the
United Kingdom government was Abridged
by the arrangements that were put in
place then in 1997. for those of us who
are unionists there will always be an
aspiration to an ever increasing
proximity between us
but the stage we have now reached is the
disagreement represents a significant
and major achievement by this government
it requires compels commands the ascent
of every member on this side of the
house I fully believe
for it is a serious and significant
Improvement on the protocol as it was
agreed in 2019 and why would we not at
least agree to an improvement even if we
say at the same time
it is not the last and final word and so
looking back through the last few years
with a degree
of regret
Nostalgia even for those times perhaps I
commend most strongly
I commend most strongly to this house
urgently to this house the virtues and
merits of this important and real
staging post on the pathway ultimately
to what I hope will be a final
settlement column is what thank you very
much Mr Speaker in a very brief moment
of time that I have I'll I'll make a
number of short points look we don't
like the storm and break for a number of
reasons I would never have agreed the
storm and break I think it damages and
close the investor proposition it is no
specific role for the human rights or
equality commissions the break can be
pulled before the committee can even
finish its work on scrutiny and most
importantly I think it's a very bad idea
given the number of years I spent them
storming to give the dup a veto over
anything
I want to say something as well Mr
Speaker but some of the people in this
house who will go in and vote against
this today
former Prime Ministers members of the
ERG
all of whom supported the protocol that
had no storm and break in it that far
more checks for businesses in it they're
more interested in internal Tory
politics than they are in the wishes and
interests of the people in Northern
Ireland and I would urge the dup to
learn the lesson of the past few years
the people you can trust the people who
want to work with you are sitting right
here they're not over there on the back
benches of the Tories
Mr Speaker I Thank The Honorable member
for giving way I just want to say two
things the people that we trust are the
people who elected us to stand for them
secondly The veto that was given to the
dup was given to the dup by the people
of Northern Ireland as The Honorable
member will well know who voted in a
referendum for the Belfast agreement and
that includes that includes a veto for
unionists and therefore when he decries
that he's decrying the agreement that
his party supportive of course the
agreement that the right on remember
doesn't support but the reality is we
will vote for this because it has been
made very clear that this is a vote on
the whole framework and we've been
through many a negotiation in the past
we know we understand when the
negotiation is done and the decision has
to be made and in every single
negotiation and every single agreement
there has been there have been parts of
those agreements that we haven't liked
but we've had the stomach at for the
good the greater good of the people of
Northern Ireland we see the unionist
concerns we've seen many of them most of
them addressed in this agreement and we
are prepared to make the decision on
that basis and but let me make this very
clear to this house if the dup still
refuse to go into Government after all
of this more and more people I can
guarantee you will figure out that the
best way to make the north of Ireland
work is within a new Ireland that is
where this is going and people should be
very aware of that the right honorable
member for Lagan Valley the SEC I just
did it myself we're all in the United
States last week we know the President
Biden has appointed Joe Kennedy as an
economic Envoy to try to take full
advantage full advantage of dual Market
access we met investors we met senior
members of the U.S Administration who
want to help us bring jobs to places
like Derry that have been left behind
over many years this is a huge
opportunity it is it is facing us it is
right in our face Jewel Market access to
people around this house what somebody
said earlier give their left arm to have
for their own constituents why why
Always despite some concerns even that I
have within all of that why would you
give that up the most important thing to
remember though Mr Speaker it's done
it's over the negotiation is finished
the British government the European
Union are moving forward they're moving
on they're dealing with other issues
it's time now the deal with the crisis
in our Health Service which is at the
point of collapse the deal with the
economic stagnation to get into storm to
do the work on behalf of the people and
to come back together again and work the
Common Ground there is no other
alternative
thank you Mr Speaker I am a passionate
brexiteer and I still think our future
outside of the European Union is the
best possible thing for the United
Kingdom but above all else I'm a
passionate unionist and it really does
pain me like my right honorable friend
the member for Skipton and Ripon to see
that here we are again having these same
discussions that we had in the hung
parliament of 2017-19 but for so many of
us now we do believe the deal that's
been struck by the prime minister with
support from the front bench from other
passionate brexiteers this is the best
possible deal and at any time over the
last seven years if we've been offered
this deal as a United Kingdom as the way
forward we would have bitten their arms
off and it seems to me Mr Speaker the
greatest pity that the dup honorable
members and right honorable members
opposite are not going to support this
deal today it seems to me that this is a
superb deal for people who live in
Northern Ireland and whilst I fully
respect the views and the knowledge of
my honorable friend the member for stone
I do think that the Constitutional issue
has to be taken as slightly only very
slightly different to the issue that
faces us today today we're looking at a
deal that really will work so much
better for the people of Northern
Ireland and for our Union and as my
right honorable friend the member for
West origin Devon says this will not be
in all likelihood the last we hear on
this subject but let's not make the
perfect the enemy of the good let's move
forward as one United Kingdom and vote
for this S.I
speaker
let's be clear what we're giving it to
be here today we're debating a lock or a
break which isn't necessary because the
government has allowed the EU to impose
its law on part of the United Kingdom
and the result of that is that we now
have a border between one part of the
United Kingdom and the other part of the
United Kingdom a border which is going
to be reinforced very shortly by the
building of physical posts which will be
used to monitor trade between Great
Britain and Northern Ireland where Goods
which are going into Northern Ireland
purely for the consumption of Northern
Ireland will be checked 100 Customs tax
and one in 20 physical checks and that
can be varied of course by the EU and
what's the answer government's answer to
it well unionists can can have make a
protest about it they can sign up or
take some concern by the way a
petition's concern which if there's
anything will destabilize the Northern
Ireland assembly it's a constant use of
the position of concern and the members
behind me will confirm that so first of
all there's a limit on what can be done
and secondly despite what the secretary
of state has said that he would be
buying too in fact he would have no
option to the other listen to the
particular concern from unions their
whole sex in this bill which tells us
groans on which he can refuse to do it
and even when he does even if he does
accept that he then has to go to the
Joint Committee and he has to exercise a
veto a veto which he knows will lead to
material
um impacts for the United Kingdom and
that we can be absolutely sure if it's a
choice between you disrupting relations
with the EU ironically this Windsor
framework is presented on the basis that
is to normalize relations with the EU if
that's the case How likely is it that
we're going to have pick a fight with
them over the implementation of some EU
law in Northern Ireland the truth is
this is not a storm break it's a storm
and fake it should be rejected by this
house it doesn't protect the union it
doesn't protect the Democracy in
Northern Ireland and it will not get the
assembly back and running again well
done in two seconds John Redwood the
government should not put this to a vote
now this will not work it cannot work as
a break because storm will not meet
because of it and it gives amazing
powers to the European Union
order the question is As on the order
paper as many of that opinions say I
of the country no
clear the lobby
the question is the moisture related to
the division as many of that opinions
say aye
aye the country no no oh
tell us for the eyes Andrew Stevenson
and Steve double for the nose in Paisley
and Paul girvin
of it